oggi sono qui per parlarvi di un tema
che mi interessa molto e quello del
cinema e del futuro
9 marzo 2020 tutta l'italia zona rossa
è stato un evento eccezionale un evento
unico irripetibile
io mi sentivo assolutamente colpita
affronta senza parole un po come tutti
ci siamo di fronte trovati di fronte a
un evento spartiacque un evento
assolutamente unico un evento che ci
avrebbe portato di fronte a una nuova
possibilità
ricordo quella sera di essermi
addormentata con le parole di una
poetessa mariangela gualtieri che diceva
eravamo sempre fuori di noi ci dovevamo
fermare lo sapevamo tutti dentro le cose
ad agitare le ore a farle fruttare
ricordo di essermi addormentato a quella
sera di fronte alla possibilità che in
qualche modo il mondo sarebbe cambiato
come un po tutti noi
e quella notte ho fatto un sogno molto
irrequieto un sogno molto strano un
sogno in cui mi trovavo in una sorta di
cinema abbandonato un cinema in cui vi
erano delle persone che abitavano la
sala alcuni avevano costruito delle
piccole dimore sotto le sedie altre
ancora invece avevano iniziato a
utilizzare il bagno per cercare di fare
delle docce altre ancora invece lo
utilizzavano per guardare delle immagini
le immagini che le immagini che
scorrevano sullo schermo erano immagini
di un mondo che stava scomparendo quasi
immagini i reperti archeologici
il cinema e l'archeologia delle immagini
diceva bernardo bertolucci
attraverso le immagini attraverso questi
pensieri brillanti mi sono trovata a
ripensare a quello che voleva dire al
fatto che il covip aveva portato in
qualche modo una nuova prospettiva
il covo di infront in fondo ci aveva
portato a scoprire tutta una serie di
nervi della società ci aveva portato con
una sorta di navicella spaziale nel
futuro
nel futuro ci siamo trovati a chiederci
che ruolo avessero le immagini che ruolo
avesse la creatività quale nuova strada
quelle nuove desiderio quale nuova
necessità
ed eccoci di fronte una rivoluzione
digitale inesorabile un'accelerazione
imponente impossibile da fermare
un'accelerazione che ci ha portato a
renderci conto nel nostro mestiere
quello dei di chi lavora quelle immagini
registi gli artisti ma i creativi in
genere che forse dovevamo trovare nuove
strade nel mio mestiere ci sono state
tre accelerazioni molto imponenti
la prima tutti noi abbiamo iniziato a
desiderare di avere dei contenuti più a
portata di mano di dita
inoltre abbiamo iniziato a chiederci che
cosa volesse dire veramente cinema che
cosa volesse davvero dire fare uno
sforzo economico e fisico e collettivo
per andare a vedere una pellicola e non
bastava più il global franchise non
bastava più infarcire di gossip e star
la visione ma ci voleva qualcosa di più
ci voleva il ragionamento sulla forma
cinema
in secondo luogo abbiamo capito che era
necessario il fondo pubblico fondo
pubblico per sostenere l'audio
l'audiovisivo prima era importante ora
era determinante in terzo luogo ci siamo
resi conto in questa accelerazione che
solo i più forti e sono riusciti a
sopravvivere i big hanno vacillato
i piccoli sono crollati e in qualche
modo si è sparsa la voce che di fronte a
questa inesorabile onda della storia ci
doveva essere una sorta di resistenza
quasi impossibile da organizzare in poco
tempo
lo stato dell'arte a che punto siamo
siamo al 71 per cento della decrescita
degli incassi e delle presenze rispetto
al 2019 il set sono bloccati contenuti
diciamo sono stati bloccati dall
impossibilità di ripartire velocemente
in terzo luogo c'è stato un boom dei
servizi di streaming siamo passati al
più 26 per cento e contate che
addirittura incassano cinque volte più
del box office da 60 miliardi a 12
miliardi di dollari
inoltre siamo tornati a una sorta di
annullamento dei festival in presenza in
che senso i festival sono diventati
delle una forma ibrida tra le online e
la presenza e questo ha comportato che
il cinema diciamo d'autore è arrivato
nelle piattaforme digitali ma allo
stesso tempo è stato considerato in
maniera democratica e quindi si è
allargato il pubblico e il bacino
d'utenza
ecco nel 1895 fratelli lumiere dicevano
il cinema un'invenzione senza futuro
una delle tante morti del cinema una
delle tanti morti e sancite nel cinema
durante i secoli la prima volta toe con
l'avvento del colore del suono
la seconda volta si è parlato di morte
del cinema quello zapping ovvero che la
possibilità come diceva green way di
utilizzare il proprio semplice
telecomando per decidere in maniera
solitaria arbitraria individuale che
cosa si voleva scegliere
e in terzo luogo ovviamente il momento
in cui stiamo ora il boom dei servizi di
streaming e non solo delle nuove
tecnologie
ma quindi se il cinema in qualche modo è
morto a che punto siamo beh io non credo
che il cinema sia morto in fondo siamo
ancora in questi giorni dopo questi due
anni nelle sale e quindi cosa sta
succedendo se il cinema in fondo non è
morto come dicono da quasi un secolo il
cinema si è trasformato in che cosa si è
trasformato
utilizzo questo termine che non è mio ma
è di simone arcagni che uno studioso di
nuovi media e di culture digitali
simone arcagni scrive il cinema futuro
il futuribile del cinema un tema molto
interessante
teorizza una cosa che a noi servirà
moltissimo nel corso di questo talk dice
che il cinema non è morto perché il
cinema si colloca nel futuro il cinema è
sempre
prospettiva orizzonte in che senso
il cinema nel momento in cui si ibrida
con le nuove tecnologie in cui diventa
video arte in cui diventa elettronica in
cui diventa digitale il cinema esiste il
cinema si espande come diceva young
blood nel momento in cui si espande
diventa realmente quello che la sua
natura
tanto è vero che siamo passati dall idea
di cinema come sostantivo all'idea di
cinematico come aggettivo dalla rigidità
alla leggerezza quindi nomadico
flessibile che può cambiare
cangi volo e che può raccontare il
presente
lo scrive luca bear bene ma in questo ci
chiediamo come questo possa forse
raccontare una simbiosi più complessa
una simbiosi tra umano e macchina tra
biologia e natura tra natura e cultura
eppure allora diciamo che l'incubo di
cui vi ho parlato nizio potrebbe
sembrare una favola a questo punto il
mondo sta crollando tutto cambia il
cinema il cinema vengono chiusi eppure
il cinema sopravvive e invece siamo di
fronte a un paradosso
dietro niente ogni dispositivo il più
geniale si celano l'umano scrive giorgio
agamben
sì perché siamo di fronte alla chimera
autoprodotta dello munch luz del faust
ovvero siamo di fronte a un piccolo uomo
formato attraverso l'alchimia che cerca
di essere out artico
oppure siamo di fronte a quella novella
di edgar allan poe in cui si parla del
giocatore di scacchi un celebre automa
che va in giro per le corti europee
vincendo tutte le partite ma dietro
quell auto ma in realtà si cela
semplicemente un uomo che cerca di
maneggiare per vincere questo che un
marchingegno antropomorfo
siamo di fronte quindi al fatto che
dietro ogni tecnologia dietro ogni
dispositivo che diventa violento
dominante che ci sovrasta in fondo ci
siamo sempre solo noi
che immagini produciamo oggi sono
immagini immersive sono immagini
sensoriali sensitive sono immagini che
cercano di connettersi con l'altro e con
l'altrove e in questo anche se il cinema
in qualche modo è stressato nei suoi
parametri cambia perché le tecnologie
cambiano il cinema cerca sempre
quell'altro e quell'altrove lo fa
attraverso lo schermo gli schermi e a
volte lo fa anche nella vita
grazie
[Applauso]